lock him to this video playing max power
from Denmark playing Kings Indian but
then tried to play with c5 I don't
really like the traditional main lines
of the Kings Indian fianchetto trying to
provoke him into the fire it's not not
bad or anything for white but
interesting yeah why not just just to
just take it Queen a Quincy five and
then take it yeah or maybe night you
fall I don't know I just I didn't have
any any any great concept while giving
away c5 I just thought black should have
something I am Bali's schism yeah i
can't play with 93 at some point or p3
but it's it's not very ambitious kappa
phone the problem with this kind of
setup is that c4 might be it might be a
liability in fact i think it's better to
have it on a three and on a3 and b3 but
it's not a big deal I mean why it is not
worse by any means it's just that I
think I'm with it it doesn't really am
doesn't really promise some anything
special ok 4g for ya Michael Annett
doesn't have many squares
right I better make sure that kid can go
to d7 interesting I'm very quickly
played you all I have got nothing to
fear with the Queen trade but do I want
to trade it
I don't think I wouldn't want him to
take as doesn't really help let's let's
get the Queen to be seven I like it on
b7 this is a good square irritating on
the long diagonal
try to in the long run get something
against the sea pawn if you play c5 he
always has to reckon with capturing and
playing b5 let's say d CB CB 5 ok unless
you're just preparing it I don't know
maybe but I don't mind that him and now
nitey five being the idea it's all about
the c-4 pond
hmm interesting
interesting I can play 95 to exchange a
couple of pieces but is it really
helping yeah it's not bad maybe I had to
have something I had something more
ambitious but it's a fine move no
question
now II form is another target potential
target I have a very compact position
where we're enjoying it's a bit cramped
but I don't have any any weaknesses so
I've come check I should should really
cement this position on e4 and there's
also tricks with taking on c4 if you
just from a moment imagine Luke c7 i
drop takes e4 rook takes rook takes 92
at the end winning the c-4 pond let's
let's try that hey it's a cheaper it's a
cheap trick
but it is also um ideas with d5 and and
such but about a six whole night b5 as a
move that irritates me the other one get
this going maybe be five nope doesn't
want to play be five
I'm not sure if either so it's a good
move but like to to make make some
progress I'm sure maybe it's a mistake
well it's probably no serious mistake
but ok want to take and before and then
interesting check now I will be 545 this
drilling doesn't really help I want to
use the iphone check
now have this weakness on b6 them it's
um it's not not so easy check whenever
I'm leaving the f out he's able to
attack the beef the b6 porn with rook on
the FR bouquet 6 and what I'm trying is
a bit risky maybe I can use the can King
to to cover this
check-check
check yeah don't really see how to to
get anywhere here time morning it's
probably just the drone even with d5 he
always has look aged 6 channel not worse
this is clear but China cannot really do
much check check check one the rich
don't turn check check draw a third
flight the drawer fixing on time I
fatima draw before all I can do and I
have no reason to resign the position it
wasn't it wasn't clear at all yeah
probably among members with with him
having the vporn the hour did it and
probably I should just take a draw in
this ending at some yeah it is probably
better for black but I don't really see
how check I can defend all the pawns I
thought it should be better for black
because of the the active hook with the
computer what is the computer giving it
just gives this and then each five
hmm gather computer use black a clear
advantage but I'm not sure simply
because of this I mean and then of
course I can I can prevent that but just
to just think about this club version if
I now go for the Aged pawn he's got this
counter play and this is what I was
worried about if he gets the beep on
this is this is just wrong and maybe
Adams I don't know maybe it's just that
I cannot cannot do anything even with
the open a file okay this is an
interesting suggestion the computer now
goes for this aha that this is in fact
the others is interesting I get the I
get the the passer and I still control
the a file so that there's not this
instant counterplay coming yeah this is
what I should have done and what I did
is just just good for continuing but not
really having having an edge yeah I mean
here I just just stop tried to do
something but this is checked this is
not not really helping my original
intention here was defined but this is
just just fantastic and he can take it
and planking him and now I'm I need to
check it sir key already is getting the
edge porn yeah well crappy game at the
end I tried to offer draw but it's it's
very difficult to to even managed to
negotiate the draw with just two or
three seconds per player on the clock
alright thanks for watching